when I was pregnant with my first child
this was before llenan I read an article
that told me I couldn't have it all and
I cried like honestly I cry cried like
for a couple weeks and I reached out to
you Cheryl and you said no this is not
happening you're gonna do this and
that's honestly part of the reason that
I'm still here so can women have it all
well let's ask do you ever get asked if
you can have it all can you have it all
how do you have it all so you forget ask
that no I mean I I suspect I've spent
nearly as much time with my kids as my
wife has spent with the kids so you know
so when my kids were young I doubt at
the office I worked from home I you know
I had the kids you know calling around
what I was having meetings I'd be
changing nappies but you know well well
as we're having meetings and and you
know and I've found the time and and was
allowed the time to you know to work
from home and I and I therefore think
companies should you know give men that
flexibility to to work at home to be
able to spend time at home to have
longer holidays I mean you know to
choose when they want to have holidays
and what happens is they have it all
languages on the applied to women what
have it all means is have children and
have work we assume men can have both
and they do the problem is we assume
women can't but women do and have to 70%
of mothers in the United States are in
the workforce because they have to be
and so telling women constantly you
can't have it all you can't have it all
is not helpful because they have to be
parents and work and as Richard says it
turns out fathers have to both work and
be parents too and right now most people
work does not work for parents both men
and women get discouraged from leaving
they're worried men - they're not gonna
seem as serious if they go home to be
with a child not every workplace can be
as flexible as the kind of flexibility I
think virgin or Facebook could offer